Oi gente existe muito nome estranho no
mundo agora igual ao meu acho que não a
humano em um tem mas eu acho que
escrevendo igualmente meu nome w h i n d
r s w h
e* jogo da meu nome é muito complicado
não é todinho acende with é proteger sua
internet dos vizinhos bote meu nome como
sempre não mas não tem no mundo quem
queira e aí mulher como é que tá eu tô
bem mulher e tudo Pois é mulher também
tô bem e tem wi-fi aqui tem qual é a
senha Tem sim mulher a senha Whindersson
a senha
e eu deixo uso 3G mesmo tive muita
dificuldade de aprender meu nome eu só
fico feliz quando eu percebo que tem
gente que tem história mais dramática do
que guardou Schwarzenegger por exemplo
ele vai aprender a escrever o nome dele